I've known Ben for many years he says
I'm working in this film Tropic Thunder
and he said look would you mind reading
the script I said okay he had all the
characters but the studio wasn't there I
was like you need the studio there was a
structural compression missing that
keeps the pressure on these guys that
really makes drives the story I read
this character and I went okay I said
look I'd love to play this character but
I want to have fat hands and I'm going
to
[Laughter]
dance yeah he said look are you sure are
you can you why you just be you I said
no Ben I said I really I need fat
hands and I'm I'm going to dance we did
the makeup test fat hands you know and
the whole look rained down in a Godly
Firestorm I just started moving you know
and there was no music kind of moving
like that want the goodies he just
called me he was just pissing himself